the band name is salsa windfall like
you've mentioned already I don't know if
you saw the clip of this last hey babe
episode with Chris and Sal where they're
listening to the song you put out and
they're trying to figure out what the
name salsa windfall even means the name
of his band is salsa windfall I I did he
ever explain that wait wait hold on a
second stop this that literally this
sounds like a that sounds like a burrito
place in Orlando yeah does the name
actually mean anything or how did you
and Paul come up with that Paul came up
with it we were a young man and we we
got a bunch of weed weed was a really
special thing back then you know it's
not like now where it just falls out of
every tree you walk by and he said we
should record while we were there and he
was starting to get into cooking and he
was like I'll cook he made this big
Mexican spread one night it was like
tacos and all kinds of stuff we were a
few songs in and I was like what do you
think we should call this he's like we
should call it salsa windfall he was
holding a jar salsa and I was like okay
my vocabulary was so poor I didn't even
know what the word windfall meant yeah
yeah I thought it was a fart joke